okay we have another question from
twitter janet perry asks what is your
best advice for decorating with a
roommate who doesn't have the same style
as you i love this question and i'd like
to throw it to all of our panel members
how about this move
[Applause]
[Laughter]
so many couples do not have the same
style oh my god but you know what we
always always do is like mood board it
out before we buy anything because then
you can like have the arguments before
you've actually bought something and
then it's like they're in the mirror and
you're both like i like it i hate it i
like it i have a married couple friend
who their entire house is still not
finished because they can't agree
together
i'm like you guys how can you live like
this and they're like every time it
comes up we get in such a big fight
right that we'd rather live with nothing
on the walls and no furniture i'm like
they've gotta have that conversation i
think the biggest thing is like just
like you would do in therapy you put
your top three he puts his top three and
you look at that list and you say
collectively like what is our design
style if he likes modern and you like
traditional hell blend the two together
google it out and like find images that
are modern traditional and you'll find
so many images that kind of descript
that actual design aesthetic and you run
from it the biggest thing is like you
all have to live together so make it a
happy marriage and you have a sacrifice
i love the idea of references references
are the only way
well thank you janet and our final
question comes from a mother-daughter
duo jerry and sam tyson they're here in
our audience
ladies
hi drew um i'm sam this is my mom jerry
and i actually have a question for ross
i'm going to be starting graduate school
soon so i was wondering if you have any
fun easy
budget-friendly um meals that my mom and
i can make on our weekly zoom calls oh i
love that well congratulations thank you
cool and i understand
cooking on a budget so here's something
i love to do i make a lot of food with
beans because you know like black beans
you give her a can for 88 cents or
something so what about a cute taco
night i think it's fun because you can
customize your tacos wherever you are
and wherever your mom is she can make it
her way as well all right but no matter
what i just have to say
you and your mom are so cute and enjoy
your time together i love that you're
making it a priority to have one-on-one
time with your mom so whatever you eat
as long as you guys are there that's the
main ingredient
thank you jerry and sam so very much and
we just love answering your questions so
keep those conundrums
for health wellness diet beauty design
you name it we've got answers for you
and practical funny honest ones at that
[Music]